on a vu sur le site que ça leur permet
d'accrocher le sac et le bébé kangourou
il le met dedans et ça imite la poche de
sa de sa maman des petites poches
cousues de toutes pièces pour y
accueillir koala kangourou opossum qui
ont fui les feux de forêt en australie
suite à l'appel du collectif animal
rescue les élèves de marie pierre lors
d'un atelier couture à saint léger en
yvelines ont décidé de participer au
projet en créant ces faits qu on s'est
dit bon on fait notre part du colibri et
voilà c'est oui c'est loin l'australie
oui on va pas sauver la planète avec
fanny on s'est dit on va faire ce qu'il
faut pour à mettre mesure à la mesure de
ce qu'on peut faire et du petit groupe
de coups durs qu'on est et bien
participé aussi à sa crise en ont besoin
et c'est important pour nous le groupe a
déjà envoyé une cinquantaine de poche
via le collectif qui redistribue les
créations dans les centres pour animaux
de l'effet comme ça t'as pas de couture
à l'intérieur et puis c'est amovible
comme ça et là bas ils peuvent mieux
entretenir les
bah les poches madeleine est à sa
quinzième création de poche elle a
délaissé tous ses projets personnels
pour s'occuper du confort des animaux en
détresse des premières sens je pense
qu'elles sont en australie maintenant
donc c'est c'est réconfortant de voir
que des des petits animaux qui sont
blessés peuvent être au chaud et puis
bien protégé avec nos poches
selon world wide fund for nature les
incendies auraient déjà tué 1,25
milliard d'animaux
l'atelier couture de saint léger en
yvelines près par son dernier colis
avant de l'envoyer vers l'australie